let's get to five headlines
[Music]
so the rnc convention last night night
three i hosted our all-access watch
party i think we had a good time
and i was really happy that our
all-access members had an opportunity
uh you know had the special treat of
listening to
me all night so that was wonderful for
them and there were even a few good
speakers
during the convention as well i thought
um now i'm biased admittedly
but i i thought the star of the night
the best speech was from sister dierdra
byrne
she's an army colonel a doctor and a nun
this kind of sounds like the beginning
of a joke
but it's all it's all rolled into one so
she's all of those
and she got up to speak and she did not
disappoint at all take a listen
while we tend to think of the
marginalized as living beyond our
borders
the truth is the largest marginalized
group in the world can be found here in
the united states
they are the unborn as christians we
first met jesus as a stirring embryo
in the womb of an unwed mother and saw
him born
nine months later in the poverty of the
cave
it's no coincidence that jesus stood up
for what was just
and was un ultimately crucified because
what he said wasn't politically correct
or fashionable
as followers of christ we are called to
stand up for life
against the politically correct or
fashionable of today
we must fight against a legislative
agenda
that supports and even celebrates
destroying life in the womb
keep in mind the laws we create define
how we see
our humanity and we must ask ourselves
what are we saying when we go into a
womb and snuff out an innocent
powerless voiceless life as a physician
i can say without hesitation
life begins at conception that's that's
awesome and
you know i mean you know i'm gonna like
that that's that is
right in my wheelhouse and i have to
tell you just so you know
if you're not catholic what you just saw
there
that's a a real nun okay she's got the
habit
she's defending the unborn she's very
kind and gentle but you get the
impression that she could whoop your ass
if she needed to
so those are those are nun vibes okay
it's total nun vibes
contrast that with the fake nun at the
dnc
dressed like a secretary praying to the
sky goddess or whatever she was doing
um so you know just all you need is that
contrast and i know which nun i'm gonna
choose
in the celebrity death match uh other
than that i thought there were other
good moments some good speeches
um i also thought there were missed
opportunities and i think there have
been some missed opportunities all
throughout this are the rnc
convention now they yeah they've talked
about supporting the police they've
talked about the riots and chaos they've
talked about law and order
i think there should be an even greater
emphasis on that i mean we are right now
the rnc convention is happening three
hours of prime time coverage
while um democrats are
burning down the city in kenosha you
know and so i think that
i think there's a real opportunity there
to focus in
intensely and show people what's
happening
and you know in with with with
specificity
not just saying oh right at this point
when you say rioting
it almost doesn't mean anything to
people we're numb to it i think you need
to get
into specifics and talk about specific
things that are happening
and then call out democrats by name
who refuse to condemn it or who
or who have actually actively encouraged
it
there's been a little bit of that some
of that i think there should be more
okay number two cnn has been a parody of
itself of course for years now but
what i'm about to show you is so
embarrassing and disgraceful that the
phrase beyond parody
scarcely begins to cover it watch
what you're seeing behind me is one of
multiple locations
that have been burning in kenosha
wisconsin over the course
of the night a second night since jacob
blake
was seen shot in the back seven times by
a police officer and what you are seeing
now these images
came and come in stark contrast to what
we saw over the course of the daytime
hours in kenosha and into the early
evening which were largely peaceful
demonstrations in the face
of law enforcement it wasn't until night
fell that things began to get a little
bit more contentious
things were thrown back and forth police
started using some of those crowd
dispersal
tactics like tear gas even playing very
loud sounds to push them out
and then what you're seeing the common
theme that ties all of this together is
an expression of anger
and frustration over what people feel
like has become
an all too familiar story playing out in
places
from across the country not just here in
kenosha
wisconsin fiery but mostly peaceful
protests
cnn says as a literal fire rages in the
background
um i i'm you know makes you wonder like
if they were reporting
live from the titanic a pleasant cruise
but a little damp
probably what they would say you know
people sometimes ask questions like
is there really anything new about
biased media
you know having a media more interested
in propaganda than truth is that new i
mean has it
and the answer is no of course it's not
as long as there has been anything like
a news media
it's been biased and and there's been
propaganda
i think the difference now um
between now and other periods in the
past is that
these days the media really just has no
concern for the truth at all period
they aren't even worried about looking
like they're telling the truth
and this largely is a reflection of our
post-truth culture where relativism
reigns supreme
and many of the people in this country
honestly believe that truth is
fluid and can be whatever they want it
to be and the media reflects that
and i think the media in fact reflects
it more than it drives it
the media is a symptom of the underlying
you know moral relativism uh not not
more than it is a a cause of that
let's go to number three as you probably
heard by now the 17 year old who killed
two rioters kyle rittenhouse is his name
has been arrested and charged with
first-degree murder
um and now
we we haven't seen here's what it comes
down to for me
first-degree murder is the charge we
haven't seen as far as i'm aware
any video that shows anything other than
self-defense
there are multiple videos out there of
of written house and of the two
incidents that occurred um now if if
there's something floating around out
there
evidence of an actual first degree
murder i haven't seen it and i've looked
there's still a question mark here a
pretty big one
the second shooting the one that was
caught vividly and close up
on camera that to my mind clearly
self-defense
non-controversial he's falling they're
chasing one of the writers
also has a gun um he falls they try to
pounce on him he gets
you know then he opens fire self-defense
all the way
uh i i think i think that part of it any
defense attorney is going to have no
problem
handling that you could hire me as your
defense attorney my
my my legal education involves watching
better call saul that's all i got and
even i could probably get you clear on
those charges
but then you have the first shooting and
that's the one that wasn't clearly
caught on tape as far as i know
i think from what we have seen there are
strong indications of self-defense but
you know i i don't think we fully know
yet here's what we do know though
sadly kyle rittenhouse is screwed
no matter what even if he's innocent
which he very may well he he may he he
uh
he very well may be but even then he's
still he's still screwed
because our media and system is rigged
against
people like him and they're gonna
they're gonna make an example of him
you know it's all the people talking
about problems in the system
they're right there are serious problems
in the system
it's just not the problem they're
talking about
number four the new york post reports
that a taxidermist in england has now
unveiled
his latest work it's called potable
high-five machines
and they're made using limbs uh from
rodents
uh apparently and uh reading out from
the article says his inspiration came
from wanting to help people who like to
celebrate and greet each other with a
high five but are concerned about doing
so during chronovirus he said
um they're called potable high-five
machines that are made out of rat legs
he said i've been skinning rats to make
other things but i accidentally tore off
one of the legs when i was making and
i was making an abominable snowman which
have heads made from rat scrotums
i don't want to waste it or just throw
it into my tub of odd odd toes and
scraps of ball
sack so i thought so i thought it might
be nice to make a portable high-five
machine
okay well that makes sense personally i
don't know why you wouldn't
take your tub of toes and ball sack and
make like a nice stew
or even a dip for your tostitos
to serve when your fellow serial killers
come over for the the game on sunday
now let's take a look at this creation
here there it is
there's the the high five machine
absolutely horrifying
imagine waking up tied to a chair in
somebody's root cellar
and you look around and you see that
you see that right there what would you
think
and then you look to the other side of
the room and you see little snowmen
made from rat scrotum and then you say
to the other person tied up in the room
with you
hey it looks like that snowman is made
from a rat scrotum
and they say to you how can you so
easily identify a rat scrotum
and you say because this is my basement
and then you take out your axe and kill
him twist ending you didn't see that
coming
got a little dark there at the end all
right um number five
finally a video has gone viral i'm not
sure who this girl is or even if this is
supposed to be a joke or not but uh
people are taking it seriously
and uh and um are
mocking this girl my perspective on it
might surprise you a little bit i don't
know
but first watch this i was just doing my
makeup for work and i just wanted to
tell you guys
about how i don't think math is real and
i know
that like it's real because we all like
learn it in school or whatever
but who came up with this concept and
you're like pythagoras
but how how did he come up with this
he was living in like the i don't know
whenever he was living but it was not
now
where you can like have technology and
stuff you know
like he didn't even have plumbing and he
was like let me worry about y
equals mx plus b which first of all how
would you even figure that out how would
you
like start on the concept of algebra
like
what did you need it for you know
because like i get
like addition like hey if i take two
apples and then on three it's five you
know
but how would you come up with the
concept of like algebra
because what would you need it for you
know what i mean like what would you
need it for back then
you didn't need it so why would you come
up with it now of course people are
sharing that and mocking her for being
an idiot
uh that seems to be the consensus but
i'm gonna i'm going to unironically and
i have to say that because no one can
ever tell when i'm being ironic or not
so unironically i will defend her here
because what she's posing is actually a
very
intelligent question and one that
philosophers and mathematicians
have been debating for thousands of
years in fact the people that are
calling are stupid have
only revealed their own stupidity you
know
oftentimes you can tell how dumb someone
is
by how they react to an abstract
point or question like this ah that's a
stupid question no it's just you're
stupid
so you don't understand why that's
actually a really intelligent question
um is math real that is not a stupid
einstein wondered about the same thing
was he stupid there is a debate about
whether math is
innate to the universe a fun or you know
sort of a fundamental facet of reality
or whether it's a human construct in
other words is math invented by people
or did we
discover it entire philosophical
theories have been built around the idea
that math is not innate
um that it was invented which is what
the girl here is suggesting
and i don't happen to agree i think matt
is math is innate and mathematics is
just the process of noticing and sort of
attaching
symbols to these innate patterns in the
universe so math is real but symbolic
you know we use a little sideways m to
denote
the fact that there are three units of
something
um we could use any symbol for that so
that's symbolic but it is still a fact
and uh that there are three or whatever
word and symbol you want to use to
denote it but what the girl is
demonstrating here is a capacity for
abstract
thought just the practice
of taking something basic
and questioning why it exists or if it
exists
or why it needs to exist that's a
capacity that i think we should
encourage in young people and i think
one of the problems with the
public education system is that it's not
encouraged you know if you're in math
class and you're learning algebra
and you raise your hand and say you know
and start asking philosophical questions
about
whether this is you know a fundamental
pattern of the universe or whether this
was invented or what's what's you know
there's not gonna be time to get into
that with you and you're just gonna be
told to shut up and do your
do your assignment um but these are
exactly the questions that i think
young people should be encouraged to
think about and talk about
i think most people never wonder about
these things because they're not
intellectually curious and their brains
can't deal very well in the abstract
but when you see this i think when we
see this in kids we should encourage it
and not go
you [ __ ] what an idiot and make farting
noises in their faces i i don't think
that's
the right response when young people are
asking abstract questions that's just me
though that's my thought
thank you for tuning in to the daily
wire one of the fastest growing
conservative media outlets in the entire
country if you enjoyed this video uh be
sure to give it a like
and a subscribe to our youtube channel
so you don't miss out on any of our
content